[Music]
part of me is everybody there because if
everybody's there wanna thank you all
for coming to the wedding i'd appreciate
you're going even more i mean you must
have lots of better things to do not a
word of it to paul remember paul you
know the man i'm gonna marry but i'm not
because i wouldn't ruin anyone as
wonderful as he is but i thank you all
for the gifts and the flowers thank you
all
that is absolutely amazing and that is
matthew doyle in the hit broadway
musical company he snagged a tony
nomination for the role the critically
acclaimed show is up for nine awards on
sunday and our jamie whack sat down with
doyle ahead of the tonys to discuss his
show-stopping performance and what this
nomination means to him
when my name came out
i just dropped my head into my hands
kind of in shock this is a recognition
of my time here in my effort i have
poured my heart and soul into this
industry and this career and i just
thank my lucky stars every single day
because i never ever dreamed big enough
for this this is amazing can you imagine
your life without theater no no i really
can't it's my
my church my religion
at just 35 years old matt doyle has
spent almost half his life on broadway
stages with roles and hits like book of
mormon and warhorse thanks a bunch but
i'm not getting married but it's his
performance in company that earned him a
tony nomination don't just stand there
i'm not getting married and don't tell
paul but i'm not getting married today
show is a re-imagined production of
legendary composer stephen sondheim's
musical originally written 50 years ago
sondheim is i think the shakespeare of
our time and just like with classical
theater you can apply his work to any
situation and scenario and if it's well
directed it will sing and be just as
relevant as ever and i think that's
what's happened here how do i look funny
yeah
in this rendition doyle plays an openly
gay man riddled with anxiety on his
wedding day oh what are you so happy
about all the time it's also important
to take a step back and recognize that
no 50 years ago this was not possible
and now we're here in this moment and we
can tell this story gay marriage is a
thing we can tell this perspective and
we're just doing it no commentary it's
just out there and i hope
that there are
young kids coming to the show and
recognizing that they get to be
themselves on stage that that is
possible dole's performance of getting
married today explores the pre-wedding
jitters of his character jamie i don't
know what you're waiting for a wedding
what's a wedding it's a prehistoric
ritual where everybody promises fidelity
forever which you get either a partial
or full standing ovation can we just say
it's not just a show stopper
you really do stop the show it's it's
unbelievable i
i cannot believe that happens
[Applause]
[Music]
in the audience get to recognize that we
all have the same fears and anxieties
and that we all feel the same
pain and confusion around love and that
it's okay you know it's okay to feel
that way it's okay to have those dark
thoughts because the shame around it is
what makes it painful two years with a
psychiatrist and look where it leads his
work has drawn praise not just from
critics but from his co-stars like the
iconic patti lupone it's just kind of
wonderful to see
to be backstage to hear the response
to matt
i'm really happy for that i'm happy that
he's having this tremendous success
the song is deeply personal for doyle
who is open about his own struggles with
mental health it is literally
a deeply felt panic attack
set to music and lyrics do you agree
with that i hope that's what's coming
across because i know what a panic
attack is i've dealt with them my entire
life i was first diagnosed with a panic
attack disorder when i was
only 13 years old and i know that
physical feeling and that mental feeling
and the way one bad thought triggers the
next bad thought until you get to the
most irrational ending imaginable so i
get to tie so much of myself into this
song every night how afraid were you to
reveal
this part of your mental health
in in recognizing that this song matched
something about you i think at first
it's very hard to be that revealing of
yourself but something that i've learned
over the years with my depression
anxiety and and with my panic disorder
the more we talk about it the easier it
is to deal with and i think that's why i
was able to open myself up so much to
this song because i recognized that it
was actually healing for everyone
including myself
hmm
wow it's just the fact that matthew
doyle is opening up about these issues
talking about being lgbtq talking about
panic attacks talking about just being
yourself on the stage and not being
afraid of those demons and embracing
them almost i know that that's going to
change the mind or the hearts of a young
child who's watching that interview that
jamie did and for the better yeah on top
of just being talented yes there's also
that
and having the respect of patti lupone
yeah you know
and as for that performance the big
cheese around here shauna thomas who
knows theater reviews it this way five
words he is amazing amazing uh cheering
for you matthew churn for you you can
watch the 75th annual tony awards at 8
eastern 5 pacific right here on cbs and
on paramount plus